JoJo...
I've loved JoJo like my whole entire life.
I want to be her one day.
I've always wanted to be a popstar.
This is my dream.
I have the ability to be a star.
I wanna be famous.
Hi!
We are gonna make you
guys the next phenomenon.
There's something missing in
the world of music.
And that is kids pop original music.
So, we're making a pop group and I want
kids that have something special about them.
I'm cool and I'm swaggy.
I feel like I'm a beast and I'm awesomely good.
We're costumed, we're highlighted,
we're glitzed, and we're ready to go.
She's been undefeated for two years and
she's only been dancing three years.
Kinley, please take it out of your foot.
One, two, step in time to make
a perfect combination.
What it takes to be a popstar is unimaginable.
Five, six, seven, eight.
This eight week audition is not just singing.
Ooooh!
It's not just dancing.
It's everything.
We brought eleven kids here
that might have it.
Now we gotta see them deliver.
I feel confident and I'm gonna crush it.
See who can perform.
That was incredible.
We want them to be triple threats.
Tatum, you've got the talent. Other girls
have all confidence and not the talent.
And I know what they are looking for.
They won't cast two girls that look so similar.
She's seeing Kiya as a threat.
I'm not scared of you Angie,
I'm not intimidated by you.
I'm not scared of you either.
It's not about who went home,
but it's about who stayed.
It's almost like when you watch a movie,
and, like, the bad guy wins.
Ha ha ha!
Go out there and give the best
performance of your lives.
Your costumes are huge, your music is huge,
your performance is huge.
You need to be huge.
Big, big Kinley, big!
Jump around! Jump around!
Last week I was at the bottom.
Now I'm at the top.
We're not used to being at the bottom.
This is not easy.
If you don't kill it, you're going home.
You don't understand how bad she wants this.
I'm scared and I just want her to be in this group.
Let me just comfort her.
You are the very first member.
Make some noise for XOMG POP!